you're welcome to this video this is the
three minute madness yep haven't done
one of those for quite a while but here
we go three-minute chest and I'm going
to play aggressive stuff as aggressive
as I can blame ya within limits are
going to play complete bunker stuff but
let's try go for h5m okay so he
prevented that and let's go off to g5
there's often an annoying square so off
to off to them can I get can I get to
ask in quickly here if I've is going to
lead to trades okay what about this it
recurs reform but I get an e5 maybe oh
ok so very direct way to play Teague
stakes hmm that doesn't look too great
so let's take here and go with d5 yeah I
have to be relatively quick here this is
three minute chest that's not my usual
time control so they have to be extra
alert not to spend so much time yeah my
own king is a big problem here he might
play something like 94 Queen B 6 and hmm
yeah Queen B 6 he's already coming up
with that one how do I get get developed
Bishop to e3 hmm would be great but I
cannot do that at the moment I'm playing
this to be ready for Nyjah form and yeah
playing quickly also makes sense how do
I play that him okay I want to go queen
bee three Bishop e3 something like that
but
he had night before this is why I went a
three but this is very slow so not that
it's not the best possible scenario he
ever really not I'm just worse iam what
is playing really slowly here right yeah
Queen d3 still Bishop f5 yeah maybe I
have to have to look for f 70 so i can
go d6 now but you would take it I guess
so better not maybe here and I will
still take it but it might be dangerous
f7 is hanging so he cannot so easily
take you five and i might get in but
should be three I ass got Bishop g4
though hmm ok that's surprising taking
f7 now what's that really planned that
looks dangerous for black
a Bishop g4 is very irritating the whole
time but it's not playing it for some
reason right now Bishop g4 I might have
queen of two by the way i will also flag
mercilessly and three miniatures so
don't don't worry about that one okay
i'm taking the rook their black resign
yep ok next one yeah 3 minute chest is
really am yet not much of a difference
two bullet to me so i really don't care
much about the type of things if you win
on time you win on time so come on give
me a game that's kind of a crazy
position but probably not that great now
rating is not high here it should be
higher but i really never play three men
if I do I'm usually not well taking it
too seriously huh why don't I get games
yeah it's kind of strange here I Oh
Maxie so all ready for the Latvian here
we go people simply don't know how to
play again said that's amazing this is
really not that great a wide set up I
mean it's playable of course it's not
terribly bad but it's not exactly a
refutation either so let's keep that
yeah came probably here I have to make
sure not to fall into this time time
trap yeah to play just like a
five-minute game and then wonder I am
losing one time it can easily happen ok
thats that's completely harmless check
like what I just have the better better
development here um I got something
better even know probably not but let's
take do this scaling huh okay yeah okay
keep it simple this is just giving black
the better position maybe I had
something better I don't know but it's
simple I'm just more active in this
position having a very slight advantage
nice gifting me a temp oh that's nice
could have played Bishop b3 immediately
threatening to double on the second so
we has to do this and this isn't fun for
white it really isn't I have a very
clear planner marching up to e4 with my
king so let's see what he's trying to do
trying to untangle King up there okay so
off we go to FYI guess let's gain space
he's still tied to the Jeep on
ok I think g4 is probably right yep
gaining more space oh no I don't you
don't know I have to react to that him
and I'm sure I think he's probably
running out of moves in short autumn g3
ok it's not doing that so it allows me
to actually enter here let's do that
check white person yes that was a total
triumph for the Latvian people simply
don't know how to refute that don't ask
me why it's it's very easy to do but
they they all play you take the five I
know that it's not in the focus huh it
wide players what to do against the
Latvian but you just take only five with
the night and are clearly better it's
not much to even learn them ok let's see
next game you already got a game
requests out
yep let's see ya by the way um we are
currently gain oops started it's good to
go um I'm currently a close to my longer
summer travels yeah i'm off on I've got
some vacation coming I also have some
work-related activities playing some
chest but what I was trying to say is
that during that time when I'm away I
won't have any other videos on the
channel other than the blitz games i
have from pre produced tons of blitz
games that will be on even during my
absence but there's nothing else i
simply cannot do any let's say
tournament coverage when I'm weighing
holiday have to do some kind of relaxing
once in a while but as right before my
my my travels start I'm going to play a
couple of like those things or maybe
post something I'm even yeah more
serious on my channel so look forward to
that the next couple of days yeah i'm
just going to fire here I don't really
see why not getting some attacking
pieces here against this king I play be
three against the French which is not
that great but I have played it a bit
recently and people simply don't seem to
know how to handle it I get great
positions like that ok so maybe here and
then take f6
I could have taken f6 and g5 it's
probably easier huh yeah that would have
been easier you can play night at four
there's no particular reason not to yeah
should have prevented that I take f6
yeah let's do that and d 55 is gaudy 5
unfortunately labid rukia 10 yeah he has
no way to cover that actually I'm a
rookie one yeah I adits check okay so
let's get the King on the side yep
threatening some discoveries and trg7 is
going to come you really have to handle
three minute just like bullet just move
move move move it's nothing else being
aggressive really lays off your signs
okay cool next one yeah can I gained
some rating points it would be funny I
with that Frankie opening the opening
choice but anyway it's not really that
important in blitz okay new game
but don't get a gay Mia what's going on
let's check this and then and there's
more five-minute action at the moment
usually you've got more and three but
currently it's Game five started you had
something ok let's go for some stuff
again this ok why not it seems to work
well people usually take the pawn yeah
just fire away here with no big regards
to what the position is actually about
ok let's try to irritate him just being
aggressive yep so he covered all of that
95 business um yeah how do I develop
like this probably on deform I always
have nitey form let's go from here ok up
correctly about the Queen og 3 is not
doing that much and I wonder do I go III
here let's do that nice he's going up
d43 actually home ok that's not good
actually prevented that ok that move is
not so dangerous I think it takes you 30
take with the palm that's even a pretty
big mistake I think yeah yeah I know
I've got see for coming why this much
better now mmm c4 is the problem ok
maybe you can can play like that but
it's not it's not looking good
okay i'm going to going to win that
material them he's got some compensation
possibly on the dark squares ojala just
like that just stupid young I didn't
look at that yeah I'm always inclined to
play very quickly in three minute and
sometimes it costs me it's not that CLE
actually because um there was this
attack on the on the night so it's to
checking them anyway now 95 that's to do
95 if I'm giving away the pawn that's
not the end of the world least I get
stuff just like 95 every five
and get in okay just just quick quick
quick everything else is secondary in
three minute threatening Queenie six and
i'm not getting made it yeah he says I'm
getting made it uh-huh it's really true
mmm I have whooped you three so okay I
can't take that first mmm batik here on
can also check on d5 with the rook but
that's not going to be okay so let's
cover like that his queen is not doing
much at the moment someone check here or
queen to d7 threatening again the ship's
III mmmm
check yeah check maybe you should see
three I can take c7 NC three that should
be good checks take your first time
morning now grab this check check first
not sure about that and now here his
queen doesn't have a great square to go
now I am I going to to do this Queen
cannot invade with the Queen quickly I
could have taken in d5 may I should have
done that okay check check but not knows
no second thoughts yeah just go go ahead
you might have the check their word
don't share simple way forward
it's not check well now Queen chat
window I can take and click in d6 but I
can go up to gchat check k check check
ok
check I'm doing up here I really do
check check let's get the chick there
check ok check yeah yeah yeah I know
Jack you've got some chicks black4 fits
on time at least I one on time here ok
starting so mr. loxton what can i play
what is kind of crazy let's go let's go
with the dutch made some dutch ok he's
going for a gambit himself that's cool
yeah they go no we need to it so they
nobody do well ok I don't mind dad um
with this played can i play this oh is
this too much it could be a tad too
aggressive I bet okay i can take care
right what is he doing now with this
pawn down we'd be four maybe hmm
interesting
but i'm not sure you cannot castle long
let's just get this developed he's got
the eyes get this night out which is the
problem but still let's get this out and
my development is just terribly bad that
that could be the real problem here he
cannot cancel but there that's cute but
if I have no development oh but his
Queen has a problem what is this your
queen has a problem what are you doing
with everybody check I guess that's
that's the only thing that you can do
the only issue is that i'm still not
quite coordinator jam we should basics
check yep have to get activity here get
my bishops into the game that that was
that was successful maybe I get in look
before Ruby to check here so any better
move maybe Chad did I had something
better that could could have been right
again that's just it looks kind of funky
a look on if the rooks yeah but yeah
it's a it's some attack there against
her against see form so should I sec the
exchange I don't know
doesn't look really necessary let's do
this threatening I a13 bouquet three
actually that's quite nice and a to hang
so not bad at all also just Bishop takes
affords really yeah I just take that
right it's no big issue about it okay i
can check here check and take a two
white resign yeah how I'd lose this
basically everything here ok next one
yeah I'm not going for big analysis yeah
this is just some some quick fun did I
we know the games really with that kind
of crazy attitude I guess I did who is
that Antone cousin okay yeah well really
three minute chest you just have to fly
away it's nothing it's nothing
sophisticated about it yeah there's
actually some action going on in the
three-minute poor but it takes a while
till I get a game strange
yeah that was a I just blunder to screen
there is a look at four yeah yeah it was
kind of a help help Queen trap you okay
I don't that takes over earlier that's
strange give me a game please game
started Spears okay so let's go through
small reaction people decline that all
of the time that's actually a strange
gambit but okay he allows me to take
that that looks nice I don't like blacks
position at all that looks really good
for me good development good structure
it was a strange idea to let me take on
d5 and especially in combination with b6
this is a this is not very am NOT a very
good structure I'm almost invariably
playing this one king of AI castles
there was bishop age six but I'm not
even sure that I would have taken that
probably I would have but yeah that's
just fantastic position
yeah he tries to play d6 it seems so
let's think about it can I go for some e
6 business yeah many many moves are good
actually but what am I playing I mean if
I do that and he plays d6 he is just
opening up his own position down so okay
he didn't he didn't go for that at the
end so let's just move the Queen
somewhere where it's not obstructing
things before him before I did Knight to
g4 let's go let's go ahead night to d4
jam his queen his queen I'm Her Majesty
his candle going left and right without
any particular goal really that's kind
of cheeky okay he wants to take c3 here
and possibly what Queen Bihar something
oh maybe f five maybe four have six I
don't know difficult hmm ma'am maybe not
the best one I wonder it looks like a
pretty nice position but it probably
wasn't the best possible way to play so
what's going on here this is this pin is
super annoying and he has night between
the mix might be towards a problem
hmm I only never square for the bloody
Queen
time morning wow I really screwed that
one up I don't have a square that's cool
I just be three which is completely
completely bad Wow okay well how did I
screw that up Queen the Queen invasion
air was surprisingly surprisingly
problematic I can just just take take
you 1 and I still have a nice nice
compensation but it's never enough at
least them it's never enough unless he
helps me with some things back rank my
bloody back ring check need to Canada's
bishop somehow coming to be 4i is there
a possibility to get that in what to h6
nice checking me no it's not check check
check is giving me all chance of
material so I'm going to take check take
it
well check check what's going on here
nobody knows that check it's definitely
not playing it chat laying it in the
best possible way check that much I know
check check check check check check
check ah technical plea for no talking
check up check mate oh whoa one tenth of
a second hehe ok it was fun ok and I was
completely busted him okay just one more
game there's not nice job I do actually
know that guy I might know him nope he
said nice job nice job first off I might
know I miss from the Netherland so but
he's got no name in there ok let's see
another game let's just one more game
yeah this is the typical thing one just
one more game
okay come on give me a game I don't want
to wait here game started okay just soon
International Master t.t bulan who is
that name there nope so let's say you
would see maybe the good old Leningrad
Dutch it's rather high rated so let's
see I don't really know look Brooke be
one ask our next move but I don't know
how this is related really like that
it's really you get absolutely cannot
spend lots of time you just have to fire
yep getting out of any possible checks
or whatnot mmm hey I'm checking b5 now
if he if he allows it seems that I have
enough control over d5 to do that maybe
no please preventing that so let's go
here just put a little bit more pressure
there on a pawn and he's going to be
seven aha so still what is the Queen
doing okay interesting so let's let's be
quick here okay takes to d5 or to a 44
looks good even d5 comes into
consideration yeah I can do that it's
not not a big issue 92 93 is possible
and I have an air for coming or this one
4g phone
I've got quite some space here thats
it's important here we go and that was
quick whoa so he allows to farm and I
don't not sure about this let's let's
just get this on and now Bishop g4 for
Bishop f3 I can also take c5 but putting
the bishop on your three looks good if i
can do that i should add that even
rhymes you just have to check their on
c3 it's not super dangerous I don't
think so
Jan that looks very dangerous fam yeah
tries to trade queens but i don't i
don't agree to that so g4 for us and
then take is six i can also take it six
why not just get this get this over with
okay editor's this is a bit harsh maybe
but that said aggression is is key and
three minute and i'm going to be an
aggressive price as aggressive as
possible so over here i will create
create three this kind of thing okay can
also try to enter via a to his king is
is in a tricky spot rook g4 h4 is also
possible he wants to check their home
well that's understandable but still a
hook age form is quite dangerous
so really what is happening after o
gauge for am I not winning then I don't
see it have five I take the bishop no I
don't see it check I don't have root k 1
what an oversight I totally forgot that
I totally forgot that I'm not on a
one-time warning jesus oh what is what
it was a stupid blunder okay and I
cannot take only for because I'm ate it
how stupid
yeah I having to move what a joke there
was such a good position I know I've
already made it home I can do this maybe
where's he going with the rook that took
me far too long I can still I can still
take their of course and i still cannot
let play rookie ok black guy made it on
yourself I have no I have no move yeah I
was a totally winning position of course
totally winning even here Luke age four
how am i winning look h2l takes on c2 I
was simply I was simply not registering
that I have not I don't have week a one
I was thinking rue k1 and he resigns I
Queen f5 even Wednesday and Queenie for
is still winning for black but by now it
was tricky with the time okay well i
hope you enjoyed that somewhat wild ride
thanks for watching